[Music]
you're in Magic Mike and all the ladies
on my staff obsessed with this movie and
when it premiered they all went to the
midnight showing hooted and howled is it
fun I mean this is a movie where it's
you and these very attractive men and
they're stripping is it was it fun to be
on set and watch these guys
stripping yeah I'm asking a question cuz
I'm not sure that women I this is me
just being ignorant I know guys like to
watch women strip but I didn't know
women are watching it in on a different
level is that right well yeah I I would
never want a boyfriend or somebody to
strip for me and I would never go to one
of those clubs were guys strip I would
go watch Channing Tatum and Matthew
McConaughey strip me their movie star is
that that's fun but I don't I don't
think it's something that I would ever
want someone to do for me I think that I
would I would really enjoy you know how
like Channing is a really great dancer
but it's if a boyfriend ever was dancing
or and striven for me I would definitely
like I would like focus on his body and
then block out his face so why is that
you want to dehumanize you know what
does that mean like you can't
yeah well it's because the worst part
about I think male strippers is is the
sexy face they make you know they're
just like everyone's got like the sexy
look the II have a sexy face if it's
this
[Applause]
that's a sexy face that's also I think
something's burning case
but now you dance with that so you do
sexy base and then you dance right right
and I'll feet I block this out and this
is fun this is okay
[Laughter]
script and I made this face that
stripper hello
[Applause]
so it has a guy ever stripped for you I
mean has really stopped yeah this is a
boyfriend would do for a girlfriend it's
no no I I what I find attractive is a
you know guy like if a guy is good at
basketball or if you run fast I'm like
that's you must you must be smart I just
like the guys who you know play sports
like that's attractive a guy that's a
sexy to you as someone who does
something well yeah maybe maybe you can
imagine that translates into other
skills yeah like I don't know what I
mean like a sexy face you made earlier
yeah yeah I see a guy who can throw a
fastball and I think this I didn't need
to mock you on your own no were you
mocking me
I didn't think you weren't after I sent
you flowers and everything you'll see
you'll get them they're growing them
it's a service where they grow them
they may harvest them and then they send
them to you you know iid have to say
before I saw Andy backstage and and I
feel a little uncomfortable because he
says you know I watch Magic Mike it was
a lot of fun I said you like he said yes
but then he said he had one big problem
with it and I thought that he would say
being a guy there wasn't you know enough
you know female nudity because it's all
and his problem was what Andy that with
all those dancers none of them are
getting gay with each other
[Applause]
I gotta tell you Andy says this after he
sees every movie
the Penguins of Madagascar
people aren't doing it I mean that would
be the time for dudes to get to it he
said it without any kind of
embarrassment or hesitation well that's
him it never is embarrassed about
anything he was born without
embarrassment look at him circus the man
without embarrassment I just felt it was
it was it was lacking and yeah you know
I having a movie about ice cream and
nobody eats it
[Applause]